[Music]
all right kids look at that this
watching of the last Skywalker trailer
is sponsored by Jay and Silent Bob
reboot now on tour all over the country
go to reboot Roadshow calm we've just
had a show last night in Detroit and it
was fantastic we kicked off the tour in
Jersey
then we went to Chicago Detroit tonight
we're going to Grand Rapids day after we
go to Iowa
it's been fun man but a lot of people
been asking how do I see this movie if I
don't go to reboot bro show right now on
Friday October 25th that's this Friday
you can see Jay and Silent Bob in a
theater near you in New Jersey where we
play basically every place we play on
the tour the movie then opens in that
area it's a platform release so on
Friday the 25th you can go to a theater
and you can see Jay and Silent Bob
reboot forgot the name of my movie
little blaze in New Jersey the central
Jersey area where we played check
theatre four listings I'll probably put
up on reboot Roadshow dot-com a click
that you can find out where it's playing
Chicago it opens in theaters in Chicago
Detroit it opens in theaters in Detroit
and Grand Rapids so every place we're
touring this week the movie opens on
Friday in that area so if you missed the
fathom event screenings and you missed
the reboot Roadshow tour this this is
your chance band this weekend go out and
see Jay and Silent Bob reboot it has
been lovely for me I've just been every
night's like a warm bath where you know
like consensual mermaids or men come up
out of the tub and blow you it's it's
fantastic
oh my god it's watching this movie with
the audience that it was made for
there's like a religious experience I've
had a [ __ ] blast so if you saw to see
it if you
and see it with me and J the reboot
Roadshow tour reboot Roadshow com
hey Chattanooga we added a second show
for you man and you know pick up the
pace
hey Houston we added a second show for
you pick up the pace man tickets at
reboot Roadshow dot-com but if you can't
see it on the reboot Roadshow you can
see it you know as it as that our tour
leaves your area then the movie opens
there it's a platform release and New
Jersey Cop Chicago Detroit and Grand
Rapids the movie just opens in theaters
being paid normal price to see it and
like like a normal person like a like a
regular filmmaker
alright so enough of that man let's get
to the to the task at hand we're on tour
so I haven't gotten to do a lot of
things I've been doing a lot of press
for the movie and stuff and the other
day somebody was like have you seen the
trailer the other night and I was like
nah I was on stage so the trailer
dropped last trailer they're saying for
the rise of Scott Walker which means
this is the last trailer for the Star
Wars saga there'll be more Star Wars
movies trailers don't get me wrong but
I've been following this saga since I
was a kid man walked into a theater in
1977 with my parents walked in that
theater I was little Catholic boy I was
an altar boy walked out of that pier
converted I was a Jedi man suddenly I
found my purpose I found my religion I
love these movies been talking about him
for years I couldn't wait to see the
movies that Lucas told us about there's
a Time magazine cover story of the
Empire Strikes Back from like 1979 80
and in it Lucas khouzam is the second
movies me nine of these [ __ ] man at
one point they're gonna be fighting on
volcanoes Darth Vader and Ben Kenobi
Isaac ah even as a kid and then they
didn't do it then one day he was like
I'm done after a Return of the Jedi
right and he was finished and then
thankfully he came back years later he's
like we're gonna do the prequels and you
know they happen and then that led and I
like the prequels that that led the way
for this man like so to reboot and
and the finishing of the saga like which
that I was promised as a kid man in that
first world way and I want that that
finished and we're about to have it so
JJ did force awakens Rian Johnson did
last Jedi
JJ's back to finish out the star not
just the trilogy for the Star Wars saga
with rise of Skywalker the trailers
online we're gonna watch it right now
line it up my press play turn up the
volume and here we go that didn't work
now we go alright there it is
Lucasfilm logo always a good sign okay
jungle planet man bow helmet Falls
Red Lion that little ball that's what
Luke was practicing ominous this is our
first taste of 1977 and tastes like a
happy childhood childhood mental ago but
warm popped on ticket for bull valpha
sticks everybody say hey was Rey in
Silent Bob I could never be a Jedi
there's too much running around look at
this Legion em Meetup man looks like
Lando's holding court oh my god man
Wesley instead Wesley's not in that car
I'll get it sick Oh Star Wars look at
this I can't you know what too much is
happening I'm gonna pause this I'm gonna
start again because I can't
it's overwhelming I've never done this
before man like too much is happening
let's go back to the start [ __ ] all
right here we go
God is excited okay man we got that
Lucasfilm logo that Rey is that helmet
is from Star Wars the Lucas tracks with
Ben Kenobi and [ __ ] like that and that
will fall so 7 1977 vibes man but coming
I could never be together glued all this
running around I'm a chair stability
give me a throne
leaving that meetup man looks like
Lando's holding court showing off his
pitch and when I roast eco he's back out
of bloodshed a Star Wars boy bad shot
that's the tanti for that [ __ ] man
that's the [ __ ] from the openings of
Star Wars that's leadership where
banners come up everybody this is a
consular ship whereas damn bad
Oh kylo Ren man this obscene kylo Ren
makes me wetter than ray on top of a
Death Star knows that looks like a Ralph
McQuarrie design of a growth like that
[ __ ] man and the ship just comes up out
is that ice or water they got all the
ships I want all those toys and that's
all the kids are back I cannot [ __ ]
wait look at them [ __ ] fighting on
top of this [ __ ]
what is that man hey skip what's going
on okay
I saw this seam right here man this this
is taking one last look say hi crimes
when that happened I cry and this
it's gonna be massive Epis and Hills
finest career moment right there
look at Aries that we get the fish of
Queen ladies and gentlemen Manzo manly
the wide whinnies for heaven's sakes
horses in space goodbye horses man I'm
Kyle over with that's the full moon from
Return of the Jedi were smashing statues
and [ __ ] [ __ ] all these tents look at
all those stardestroyers man you gonna
peg what you did the solo you Menendez
[ __ ] body beach and spider chair
Oh
Terry's got the last one that's
beautiful piece of marketing ladies and
gentlemen smart marketing marketing god
damn that's how you end a saga man
I love doing what
and he could play with my Star Wars toys
anytime he wants god dammit that was
good let's watch it again
one more time here we go there's so much
to take in
I came a little bit oh my god so smart
chef Lee seven Star Wars this is Esther
capsulate the entire saga not just like
movie stuff in like women first time I
saw him in the trailer it was on jakku
it looks like bad snap Wexley he's not
next route man I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
boy bands guy that is the tan t4 for
sure man it's been tie in somehow the
ship that Leia was on them is beginning
of star would later star water man I
love the idea of them being on the water
at the Cairo [ __ ] red man
seeing these guys got me like letter
letter right away
[ __ ] dude auditions to top out
I can save the galaxy that this basket
is that good that's the Emperor
and they're coming together we're all
going to be coming together in the
theater man when this opens over our
face next chest bring its harp it's
gonna be like a Gallagher show I was
there when they record can't come shot
this exact since I heard Oscar Isaac
said what are you doing that 308 time
this scene is a ballbuster
Daniel - for a moment I thought right
there man unbelievable they better bring
all these kids together I wanna see Han
and Leia and Luke him one shot together
man JJ does that he wins the internet
forever
and you know what like horses fine
where do batons on man give me some sv
table John taste but his staff feels
like no [ __ ] school
[Music]
horses running in space how you're gonna
die [ __ ] what you did is so lame with
you I've been in since 1977 seven years
old I believe in this
unbelievable man goddamnit JJ is a
modern-day [ __ ] Spielberg he deserves
every [ __ ] penny he's done working
for Mickey Mouse but now you're going to
work for Bugs Bunny they gave him a
bunch of money over at Warner Brothers
and he deserves every penny man that
dude is just so fantastic I went to the
barn wood set when they were making the
movie and when I was there the the some
of the crew and some of the cast were
like have you seen the set on the up on
the back like as what set on back there
like there's a set that you must see we
shot it the other day is amazing like if
you go up to the the wall the Bleacher
wall you look over you're gonna see
something man is something huge and
stuff and I was like all right and so I
was talking to Jay Jay when planners
like they told me I should go see the
set that's over the thing and JJ is like
mmm
you know what you could totally do that
you can go look and it is amazing he's
going but like I urge you to wait and
see it in the theater man it's it's the
last shot of the movie and it's gonna
melt your mind and I was like like as
much as I wanted to go I didn't go so
I'm gonna find out when you all find out
I can't wait man
December 20th this movie's open and
meanwhile I got a movie that I'm touring
the road with Jay and Silent Bob reboot
Roadshow tour man go for tickets go to
reboot Roadshow calm or if you're in New
Jersey Chicago Detroit or Grand Rapids
the movie is opening this Friday in your
area you just go watch it I won't be
there Jay won't be there but you should
go watch it in the theater man if you've
missed it here's your chance you get to
go see them and that's how the movie
opens we play it into place and then
when we leave a place it opens in that
place
so enjoy folks people on tour have been
loving and I've been having a blast and
whatnot thank you for your continued
support of this Jay and Silent Bob
silliness and I'm gonna take moment off
the tour on December 20th to [ __ ] sit
my formerly fat ass in a seat watch the
[ __ ] at the end of my childhood man
there you go thanks for hanging out Jay
Allen Bob reboot reboot Roadshow com
reboot Roadshow calm a little bit for
tickets man thanks to my friend Robocop
who protected me looking over me
this whole time I'm here in Detroit
thanks man movies kids may the force be
with you
you